Honduras is one of the poorest countries
in Central and South America but there's
a new idea about to be tried in Honduras
it's called as ed a privately run zone
with legal economic and political
autonomy the laws are all in place
investors are lined up and ready to go
and the big questions about to be
answered will this actually work
this is chalo MA one of the poorest and
most dangerous cities in Honduras which
is one of the poorest and most dangerous
countries in the world but even here
experiments and governance have already
yielded some interesting results having
rules set up as people come in it
prevents from a lot of problems that
communities have in the rest of the
country with intial omma our so-called
free zones and residential cities like
los Castaignos foreign companies build
manufacturing plants and want a safe
place for their workers to live nearby
so they create their own company towns
los gusano's h Aloma is very interesting
project on the model that it presents
residence is around twelve thousand
twenty five thousand dollars it's a hard
working class but they leave in peace
that most of those people live happily
and feel safe and that's five minutes
away from one of the most dangerous
parts in the country is a tennessee are
not primera alone si
they will Lewis Lewis Castaignos has its
own rules and security and a three
strikes and you're out policy and within
its boundaries
there are several gated neighborhoods
with their own codes and norms residents
are all on rent to own leases meaning
they have equity in the land the
contrast the surrounding area is stark
kids play in the streets yards are
well-kept
people just seem proud of where they
live eco-mode como de la la primera
Colonia Morello about ten miles west of
Coloma there's an even starker contrast
on display on one side of the road lies
a giant squatters village that's filled
the river with waste on the other a
modern high-tech business park called
Altea this is a smart city we create a
very secure environment that's
sustainable and its own you know so
people work study they go to a shopping
center you can actually leave your car
open here walk around and this is the
whole idea of that the smart city
constant and it's really safe really
really sick LT is a real estate company
owned by a foreign national from
Pakistan like los Castaignos they've
been granted the autonomy to manage
their own land and set and enforce their
own rules the result is a clean secure
environment where several companies have
located their call centers which employ
hundreds of Hondurans like Edwin
Escalante who was brought to the US by
his mother as a teenager and then
deported ten years later when he applied
for a job in America soon after landing
in Honduras he got a job at Ulta I had
to start all over again from ground zero
every place you know the best way to get
a job is through a good education
Altea recognizes the power of education
and even paid to build a branch of a
public university on their property
there's nothing but a but a river
between these two properties if you want
to say on the one side you have
municipal land weak property rights land
that's basically worthless right now
because there's no clean titles there's
a mess and on the other side you have
very clear property rights you have a
private owned development
with a clear path looking for economic
benefit out of a project at the end of
the day I mean this is a real estate
project Pena says that areas like Las
Castaignos
and all Tia are small but tangible
examples of what the future of Honduras
might begin to look like once the Zed's
begin opening discussions that have been
going around with the Zetas program are
as interesting as I bet the
conversations were where the country was
being founded how should we model our
administration what should drive our
economy how to protect the people's
rights which i think is an enriching
conversation to be having in 2014 but
can a good idea
survive the messy reality of politics we
explore that question next with the
critics the strategists and the skeptics